Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je ne sais pas vous, mais quand
je rencontre une nouvelle personne,
quand la discussion s’installe,
il y a une question
à laquelle j’aime bien répondre :
«Vous faites quoi dans la vie ?»
J’adore répondre à cette question.
Parce que j’adore observer
la réaction chez mes interlocuteurs.
Ce que je fais dans la vie ?
Je suis enseignant chercheur.
Dans quel domaine ?
Moi, je travaille dans la mode.
Et voilà, voilà la réaction !
Plus ou moins consciemment,
vous m’avez scannée.
Si, si, vous avez regardé ma robe,
ma coiffure, mon maquillage,
mes bijoux, mes chaussures,
bref, mon apparence physique.
« Elle travaille dans la mode ?
Pourtant, sa tenue n’est pas du tout 2021,
ce n’est pas du tout tendance.
- C’est sûr qu’elle travaille
dans la mode.
Regarde-moi cette tenue,
c’est beau, c’est classe.
- La coiffure : oui ;
les chaussures moins.
- Il faut qu’elle me dise où
elle a acheté ses boucles d’oreilles.
Il faut absolument que je me les achète. »
C'est normal d'avoir cette réaction.
En fait, vous m’aviez déjà scannée
le moment où je suis arrivée sur scène.
Des chercheurs ont montré qu’il faut
à un être humain quelques millisecondes
pour se faire une opinion
sur son interlocuteur.
Quelques millisecondes,
un claquement de doigts.
Ma manière de parler,
la manière de me tenir devant vous,
mon apparence physique
ont déterminé en un claquement de doigts
si vous alliez me trouver jolie ou non,
si vous alliez m’apprécier
en tant que personne ou non,
si vous alliez apprécier
ma présentation ou non.
(Claquement de doigts)
avant même que je ne la commence.
Et le fait que je vous dise être experte
de la mode n’a fait qu’influencer
votre opinion sur moi.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que vous m’avez mise dans une case,
une case avec votre propre
définition de la mode.
« La mode, c’est tendance. »
« La mode, c’est l’apparence physique. »
« La mode, c’est la beauté. »
Pensez-y : si je vous dis le mot « mode »,
là tout de suite, maintenant,
quels mots, quels noms, quelles
images vous viennent à l’esprit ?
Mais en fait,
c’est quoi la mode ?
Est-ce un art, un business ?
Est-ce les défilés, les top modèles,
les marques, les magazines ?
C’est quoi, la mode ?
Certains en sont accros
et d’autres trouvent que c’est la chose
la plus frivole qu’ils connaissent.
Mais c’est quoi, la mode ?
Quand on ouvre le dictionnaire,
la mode est définie comme ceci :
« Commerce, industrie de la toilette. »
Vous allez voir que sous ces cinq mots
se cache un univers très sombre.
On sait aujourd’hui
que l’industrie de la mode
est une des industries
les plus polluantes
qui existent sur la planète.
Par exemple, saviez-vous qu’il faut
l’équivalent en eau de 285 douches
pour produire un jeans ?
Si nous continuons à consommer
comme nous le faisons aujourd’hui,
d’ici 2030, les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
produites par l’industrie de la mode
atteindront 2,8 milliards de tonnes.
Moi non plus, ça ne me parlait pas
ce chiffre-là au début.
C’est l’équivalent de 230 millions
de voitures roulant pendant un an.
Et dans la mode, il y a un secteur
qui s'appelle la fast fashion.
Les marques de fast fashion produisent
tellement d’habits
qu’elles proposent aux consommateurs
jusqu’à 50 collections
différentes de vêtements par an.
C'est quasiment une collection
différente par semaine.
Et cette fast fashion nécessite
une telle baisse de coûts de production,
une telle rapidité de production,
qu’elle peut mener à des drames.
Un exemple parmi tant d’autres :
le 24 avril 2013, au Rana Plaza,
au Bangladesh,
une usine de fabrication de vêtements,
de nos vêtements à nous, Occidentaux,
s’est écroulée sur ses employés,
faisant 134 morts et 2 500 blessés.
Et ce n'est pas le seul
problème de la mode.
L’industrie de la mode,
de par ses offres en magasin,
ses magazines, ses défilés,
ses campagnes de pub,
ne représente qu’une petite
partie de la population.
Une étude a montré
que 87 % des personnes ne se sentent pas
représentées par la mode.
La majorité des gens
ne se voient pas dans la mode.
Réfléchissez.
Vous rappelez-vous avoir vu
une femme de plus de 50 ans
dernièrement dans des magazines ?
Mis à part dans les pubs
de crèmes antirides ?
À part Naomi Campbell, pouvez-vous
nommer des top models noirs ?
Vous rappelez-vous avoir vu des personnes
porteuses de handicap dans des défilés,
des magazines, des magasins ?
Pouvez-vous me nommer une marque ayant
choisi pour sa dernière campagne de pub
une personne de plus de 70 kilos ?
Pas du tout, ou en tout cas pas assez.
Et cette invisibilité a
d’énormes conséquences.
91 % des femmes, 91 % des femmes
n’aiment pas leur corps.
La quasi-majorité des femmes
de cette salle qui m’écoutent -
vos mères,
vos femmes, vos petites copines,
vos filles -
se regardent tous les matins
dans le miroir
et n’aiment pas ce qu’elles voient.
Une autre étude a montré que des enfants
de certains pays du monde
commencent à préparer
leur premier régime alimentaire,
leur première chirurgie esthétique
du haut de leurs 9 ans.
Neuf ans.
Et tout ça, pour quoi ?
Pour ressembler à une beauté
des magazines,
à une beauté inatteignable
et qui nous est imposée.
Alors, on fait quoi ?
On fait quoi ?
On fait comme si de rien n’était ?
On regarde dans une autre direction ?
Ou on hausse les épaules
et on passe notre route ?
Je ne sais pas vous, mais moi,
je ne peux pas me résoudre à croire
qu’un monde qui m’a fait tant rêver,
qui me fait tant rêver,
un monde qui a vu naître Coco Chanel,
Alexander McQueen, Jean-Paul Gaultier,
Stella McCartney, Virgil Abloh,
Simon Porte et tant d’autres,
je ne peux pas me résoudre à croire
que ce monde-là soit si sombre.
Quand j’ai vu ces chiffres,
quand j’ai compris ces chiffres,
je me suis dit que
ce n’était pas possible,
on est obligé de trouver
une force, un bien-être,
un peu de positivité
dans ce monde si noir.
Alors, j'ai fait ce que je sais faire.
J'ai fait des recherches.
Et si je vous disais que porter un certain
vêtement, porter du maquillage,
peut avoir un impact positif sur vous,
vous me croyez ?
La première étude que j’ai trouvée
dans ce domaine a été publiée en 2012.
Pour cette étude, une équipe de chercheurs
a sélectionné deux groupes de participants
et ils les ont recrutés pour faire
une tâche bien connue,
le jeu des différences.
Vous savez, ces deux images presque
semblables avec quelques différences.
Les participants devaient
venir au laboratoire
pour réaliser cette tâche
sur une série de photos,
le but étant de trouver dans un temps
donné un maximum de différences.
Le premier groupe devait réaliser
cette tâche
dans leur tenue vestimentaire habituelle.
Au deuxième groupe, on leur a demandé
de porter une blouse blanche,
une blouse de docteur.
La seule différence entre les deux groupes
était de porter ou non une blouse blanche
pendant quelques dizaines de minutes.
Vous savez quoi ?
Le groupe de participants avec une blouse
blanche a été deux fois plus performant
que ceux qui ne portaient pas la blouse.
Les chercheurs ont expliqué que
les participants ont intériorisé le fait
d’être un médecin,
et donc d’être plus performants.
Là,
je sais ce que vous pensez.
Vous vous dites : « C’est très bien tout
ça, mais, à l’école de commerce,
on ne porte pas de blouse blanche. »
Ah, c'est vrai.
Pardon.
Ah, c’est dommage !
Ça aurait été bien si j’avais pu vous dire
que porter quelque chose tous les jours
aurait pu améliorer vos performances
à vos prochains examens,
à vos prochains tests.
Alors, écoutez ce résultat,
une étude de 2018.
En 2018, une étude de chercheurs a recruté
trois groupes de participantes,
seulement des femmes.
Ils ont demandé à ces trois groupes
de venir au laboratoire sans maquillage,
pour réaliser une tâche de 15 minutes.
Le premier groupe devait réaliser
une tâche de 15 minutes
d'écoute de musique classique.
Le deuxième groupe devait réaliser
une tâche de coloriage pendant 15 minutes.
Quant au troisième groupe,
les étudiantes devaient réaliser une tâche
pendant 15 minutes de maquillage.
Elles avaient 15 minutes pour se maquiller
comme si elles allaient en soirée.
À la fin de ces 15 minutes,
toutes les étudiantes devaient lire
un chapitre d’un livre
et compléter un QCM
en lien avec cette lecture.
Et le QCM était noté.
Devinez qui a eu la meilleure note :
le groupe maquillage.
Et les chercheurs ont expliqué ce résultat
par une meilleure confiance en soi,
une meilleure estime de soi.
Donc,
à défaut de porter une blouse blanche
pour vos premiers examens,
pensez à votre trousse de maquillage.
J’espère vous avoir convaincus
que la mode peut être utilisée
comme un outil de performance.
Et vous allez voir que ce n'est pas
le seul impact positif de la mode.
Je vous ai expliqué que la mode
avait un aspect très polluant.
Mais aujourd’hui,
de plus en plus de marques,
de plus en plus d’initiatives
se sont développées.
Aujourd’hui, on peut avoir accès à
une mode plus écologique, plus verte,
plus transparente, plus éthique.
Et en bon psychologues que nous sommes,
en bon chercheurs que nous sommes,
nous nous sommes demandé
quel était l’impact psychologique
de cette mode éthique.
Pour une de mes études publiée en 2020,
mes collègues et moi avons étudié
l’impact d’une garde-robe minimaliste.
Qu’est-ce que c’est que ça ?
La garde-robe minimaliste,
pour vous l’expliquer,
j’ai besoin que vous visualisiez
votre placard d’habits
votre armoire, votre garde-robe.
Fermez les yeux, ouvrez le placard
et regardez tous les habits.
La garde-robe minimaliste,
c’est quand vous ouvrez
votre placard d’habits
et que vous n’avez que 30 à 35 vêtements
et accessoires maximum.
Et pour cette étude, j’ai sélectionné
dix jeunes femmes
qui se sont portées volontaires pour
trier, ranger, élaguer leur garde-robe.
Et croyez-moi, il y a eu du travail,
il y a eu du tri.
Et je leur ai demandé ensuite de vivre
leur vie, comme d’habitude,
pendant trois semaines, en utilisant
cette garde-robe minimaliste.
Au bout de trois semaines,
toutes mes participantes m’ont décrit
une plus grande sérénité,
moins de stress, moins de fatigue
dans la vie quotidienne
notamment dans la prise de décision
et une prise de conscience
de l’aspect polluant de la mode.
On est allé un peu plus loin pour
une autre étude publiée prochainement.
Nous avons sélectionné
trois groupes de participants.
Un premier groupe devait venir
dans notre laboratoire,
dans leur tenue vestimentaire habituelle.
On a demandé au deuxième groupe
de porter un T-shirt éthique,
fait en respect avec l’environnement.
Quant au troisième groupe,
on a demandé aux participants de porter
un T-shirt non éthique fast fashion.
En vrai, le T-shirt du deuxième
et troisième groupes étaient similaires.
Les participants ne le savaient pas.
Seulement la présentation était
différente, modifiée.
Au bout de deux heures, nous avons mesuré
le bien-être chez tous les participants.
Au bout de seulement deux heures, un des
groupes a montré une baisse de bien-être.
Ceux qui portaient un T-shirt non éthique.
Au bout de seulement deux heures, un des
groupes a montré une hausse de bien-être.
Le groupe qui portait un T-shirt éthique.
Donc, en plus d’être
un outil de performance,
la mode peut être également utilisée
comme outil de bien-être.
La mode éthique peut être utilisée
comme un outil de bien-être et de bonheur.
Et en parlant de bien-être, de bonheur,
il y a une phrase qui revient
dans chacune de mes recherches.
Pour mes recherches, j’ai rencontré
des centaines de participants
et la même phrase revient dans
mes questionnaires et entretiens,
toutes mes études.
La clé du bonheur que l’on peut utiliser
grâce à la mode
peut se résumer en une phrase :
être soi.
Utiliser la mode pour être soi.
Ça paraît simple.
Et pourtant,
cette phrase-là,
je l’ai entendue en français, en anglais,
en indien, en chinois, en arabe.
Des gens de 16 ans, 40 ans,
60 ans et plus me l’ont dit.
Des hommes, des femmes, des non binaires,
des cisgenres, des transgenres,
des personnes de toutes catégories
sociales, de toutes nationalités,
de toutes ethnicités,
de toutes orientations sexuelles,
petits, gros, grands ou maigres.
Tout le monde me l'a dit.
«Être soit grâce à la mode»,
m’a été dit par tout le monde.
Et,
cette phrase-là, elle m’a été dite
avec un immense sourire,
ou des larmes de résilience.
Parce qu’il en faut du courage
pour être soi.
J’ai eu en face de moi,
[des personnes]
qui me disaient avec fierté
qu’elles pouvaient enfin se montrer
telles qu’elles étaient grâce à la mode.
J’ai retenu mes larmes, ou pas parfois,
en ayant des personnes en face de moi,
même parfois dans mes bras,
qui me disaient qu’enfin, enfin,
elles se trouvaient belles,
grâce à un vêtement, des chaussures,
un peu de maquillage, une coiffure.
Et ça me fait penser à une anecdote
qu’une personne très importante pour moi
m’a partagée récemment.
Pour cette personne,
c’était le grand jour,
elle allait acheter sa robe de mariée.
Et avant même qu’elle puisse
approcher les robes,
la responsable du magasin
lui a dit cette phrase :
«Si vous trouvez une robe,
qu’elle vous plaît,
que vous l’essayez
et qu’elle ne vous va pas,
ça ne vient pas de vous,
ça vient de la robe. »
Arrêtons de nous persuader
que le problème vient de nous.
Arrêtons de nous laisser enfermer
dans des cases,
arrêtons nous-mêmes de nous
mettre dans des cases.
Sortons des cases.
Sortons du moule.
N’écoutant personne d’autre que nous-même.
Allons chercher la beauté
tous les matins dans nos miroirs
et pas dans les magazines.
Être soi grâce à la mode,
c’est ouvrir son placard,
ne plus voir de simples vêtements,
une simple robe,
mais des blouses blanches
et des capes de super-héros
que l’on peut porter tous les jours
et en un claquement de doigts,
(Claquement de doigts)
être plus performant, plus heureux
et surtout plus beau.
Et c’est ça, le vrai pouvoir de la mode.
Et vous en êtes la force.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)